More people cross over illegally
here than anywhere else
along America's
2,000-mile border.
So our government
built this fence
through Brownsville a decade ago
to keep the strangers out.
It hasn't worked.
They still come...
Man:
Three-oh-four, go ahead.
Man: I have two individuals
walking up to me.
Ross: ...any way they can.
Man: They probably
rafted them across.
Yeah.
Ross:
As we waited for Border Patrol,
the constables helped me
use my broken Spanish
to welcome two people
into the country.
Get your filming now because
when we call Border Patrol,
we put the cameras down.
[ Speaking Spanish ]
Hey, bud. Hola.
They're from El Salvador.
From El Salvador?
Yes. They're going to New York.
I'm going to New York.
They're going to go
see Donald Trump.
This your son?
Yes.
Yeah, see?
Hola, buddy.
Hola.
Me llamo Jeff.
Just crossed a minute ago.
They split the children up,
that way there's no
immediate deportation.
Smart.
Yeah.
How do you feel?
Are you nervous?
What are you feeling?
[ Interpreting
in Spanish ]
What's the violence like
in your home?
[ Interpreting
in Spanish ]
Now what happens?
We'll call Border Patrol
and they'll take them
and transport them.
Where will they sleep tonight?
They'll be at
Border Patrol tonight.
What's that, like, a jail?
It is what it is,
you know?
Of course.
No.
He's brave, man, brave man.
Okay.
Yeah.
Buena suerte.
Good luck.
Welcome.
Ross:
What a kick in the balls.
One of the most exciting
moments of their lives
00:03:24,471 --> 00:00:00,000
was also so demeaning.